Elvis director baz Lerman has said that
his original four-hour cut of the film
included the king's legendary visit with
an Infamous president so will this
longer version of Elvis ever see the
light of day from Moulin Rouge to The
Great Gatsby writer director baslerman
has been known to pour his heart and
soul into every film he makes most
recently the filmmaker showed he was as
Fearless as ever with his energetic
Elvis Presley biopic Elvis are you ready
to fly
[Music]
Elvis of course Stars Austin Butler in
the titular role of the film a visually
stunning look at the life of the king of
rock and roll mostly in his last 20
years of life under the suspicious
guidance of Colonel Tom Parker Butler
not only looks like the real King he
also sounds like him in voice and song
as his mannerisms down pat and perhaps
most importantly possesses the legendary
singers bad boy Charisma and obviously
there are signature things that he did
that you know you have to be specific
about and while the film was 2 hours and
39 minutes long fans were left wanting
more especially when Lerman noted in
June that his first cut about this was
four hours long among the scenes that
were cut Lerman noted was the infamous
meeting between Elvis and then president
Richard M Nixon at the White House in
1970. lucky for Lerman Elvis was a
smashing success at the worldwide box
office earning more than 284 million
dollars in ticket sales against an 85
million production budget Colonel I know
when I'm excited an audience now as
Elvis makes it push into Awards season
the film has made its streaming debut on
HBO Max where many more viewers are
bound to hail the king meanwhile the
face fans who supported the film during
its theatrical run are waiting for the
four-hour cut of the film that Lerman
teased the filmmaker just explained why
it won't be happening anytime soon in an
interview with Screen Rants baslerman
said he's been probed about the extended
Elvis Cup by fans on Twitter all my
tweets are nothing but we want the four
hour version we want the four hour
version I think people are at my gates
with pitchfork saying we want the four
hour version while Lerman told the site
that he wouldn't write off the idea of
an Extended Cut of Elvis he doesn't see
it coming out anytime soon Lerman told
Screen Rant because it isn't just like
I've got it and you just put it out
there every minute in post-production
you have to do visual effects grading
cutting refining and ADR sound it's not
like it's just sitting there finished
and I can just push a button and it
comes out Lerman also added you'd have
to get back in and work on it to do an
Extended Cut you'd be working on it for
another four or six months or something
I'm not close to it but not now I'm a
little bit on the tired side I'm still
just trying to figure out what day it is
which yeah uh yeah I probably am
sleeping as much as one of them Lerman
likely won't be resting for long in all
likelihood Warner Brothers will be
running an award season campaign for
Elvis which means Lerman and Austin
Butler will be hitting the interview and
special screening circuit to raise
awareness of the film as critics and
Industry voters begin mulling their
nominations if and when Lerman assembles
his four-hour cut of Elvis it won't Mark
the first time a filmmaker has gone the
extra mile in such a way after stepping
away from Justice League following a
family tragedy writer director Zack
Snyder eventually retooled the two-hour
version of the film released by his
replacement director Joss Whedon in
2017. four years later with new effects
and added scenes Zack Snyder's Justice
League made its long-awaited debut on
HBO Max
[Music]
foreign